the Joe Rogan experience but what we are
now doing and the thing that troubles me
most about this movement is that if you
listen to it closely and I have listened
to it very closely it is explicitly
about disassembling the very things that
make the West marvelous right it is anti
science right it does not want policy
based on science in fact you so well I
mean you saw last week presumably that
it got nature the journal Nature science
magazine Caltech it got all of these
just absolutely top-level scientific
institutions to broadcast the hashtag
shut down stem what oh yeah no I'm not
aware of this at all oh well and this is
another thing we're losing our minds
because to me the idea that you would be
unaware of this is hard to imagine
because this is so much going on it was
so thoroughly all over my feed though
but I'm discovering this there's stuff
absent from my feed to that I should
know about
and I'm finding the same thing well
here's the thing yeah I don't read my
feet well you don't read your Twitter
feed but you're plugged into enough
people you have conversations in this
room things have to be like almost
nuclear before I'm paying attention to
them these days just for my own personal
sanity yeah I I've stepped away from
almost all social media other than
posting yeah it's actually I can say
something perfectly weird I don't really
aspire to great wealth I never have but
there is part of me that wants to be
wealthy enough that I can afford to
ignore my feeds right I can't now I have
plugged in but but anyway the the thing
that that's really concerning here and I
you know I I don't want this podcast to
be all about concern there's thousands
of scientists go on strike to protest
systemic racism and stem more than 5,000
scientists and two prominent scientific
journals shut down operations and
pledged to use the day to address racial
inequalities in science the strike
follows two weeks of demonstration spurt
by the police killing of George Floyd a
black man who died after a white police
officer put people on social media are
spreading word about the strike with the
hashtag
down academia mm-hmm shut down stem and
strike for black lives shut down
academia is terrifying shut down stem is
equally terrifying but I mean like what
takes its place what do you expect well
if you shut down academia like what are
they what are they saying when they say
systemic racism and stem what does it
mean it's representation in terms of
like the like what are they saying so
this is so sad because truly if you if
you really wanted to to raise black
people out of the quagmire at the
economic quagmire they find themselves
in if you wanted to do it on mass you
would arm them with the most powerful
tools all right the most powerful tool
and the tool that is best positioned to
address biases especially subtle biases
is science that's that's what the
scientific method does that's it's one
reason for existing is that it takes
that which you think and allows you to
see why it is wrong right it takes your
biases and forces you to see what's
wrong with them that's what science is
for now the reason that this movement is
attacking stem has to do with the
connection of this movement to critical
theory and critical theory didn't come
from the sciences the word theory is
basically pilfered all right it's being
used in a most ironic fashion critical
theory is a narrative that's now
becoming a religious movement and it is
anti stem on the basis that it claims
that stem itself science itself is
racist inherently what do they mean when
they say when they're saying critical
theory yeah what does that encompass
well my understanding is that critical
theory was born as an honorable
investigation of biases that exist
inside of our court system racial biases
and that it has now morphed into
something that its originators don't
recognize and don't respect that it has
become basically I mean you know you've
had Jordan Peterson on your podcast many
times once with me and you know he what
he talks about with respect to these
these are cultural Marxists and they are
wielding this postmodern dock
what he's talking about is critical
theory all right critical theory is
basically a a Trojan horse that exists
in academic departments that are
dedicated to its study and what it does
is it uninvent
progress in other fields and that's a
very uninteresting process when it's
hiding away in some corner of your
university where you don't have to
listen to it but what has happened is it
has now reached enough people that it
has spilled out into public and the
nonsense that you hear about shutting
down academia shutting down stem
abolishing the police all of this is
standard fare in those phony departments
when you say uninvent progress now what
do you mean by that well I mean that we
have a system and you know I'm as upset
about what doesn't work about it as
anybody but we have a system that
accomplishes a great deal and this style
of thought that all of these departments
that end in theory that don't actually
function by normal rules of logic or the
scientific process these things are an
attack there like an autoimmune disease
of the academic culture and by and large
the scientific part of the Academy keeps
its head down and it stays away from
people who believe in this stuff and it
tries to do its work but what has
happened is that the dynamics the
demographics have changed such that
these departments which weren't taken
seriously by the sciences are now
dictating terms to the sciences which
couldn't possibly be more dangerous
because to the extent that the the
argument more or less is that the
sciences are unfairly biased in favor of
those who are currently successful and
that that bias is actually preventing
people who are not succeeding under
current conditions from getting there
and therefore we need to hobble these
disciplines to level the playing field
well imagine that America surrendered
its advantage in the sciences in order
to
even if you could level the playing
field inside of the US by doing that
which you can't but even if you could
this would so hobble us in the world
that it would be an insane policy to
pursue is there any debate going on
about this clearly what they're saying
is if you're looking at the vast
majority of the scientists they
represent but when what is it european
jews are a lot of them there's a lot of
various people of European ancestry
Asian folks less african-americans less
Africans so they're saying that because
of this this is clear this is clear
evidence of racism yeah which is total
nonsense
what is it evidence of it is well it's
evidence of a number of things and you
know I find myself in two places on a
lot of these arguments on the one hand
somehow I'm sitting here on your podcast
defending academia when on any normal
day I would be telling you academia was
so incredibly broken and science has
been so incredibly incredibly corrupted
by its contact with the market that we
have to fix these things because that is
in and of itself a threat you know to
the West here I find myself saying wait
a second these people are actually
telling you what they think they think
science is the enemy and instead of
democratizing the tools of science and
giving them to the people who need them
most they want to end science so the
problems are several unfortunately
they're not tremendously interesting
they're sort of dry inside baseball
stuff but we I think we have to cover
them though just to sort of take the
legs out from under this racism argument
when it comes to representation sure so
first of all let me just say academia is
tremendously liberal and that I mean
that in both senses let's take the
honorable part of it right inside of a
university there is every desire to
bring people who do not look like the
old white guys that have done so much of
the past work in science there is a
desire to to broaden you know so it is
not true that privately scientists are
harboring racist views and talking about
them
and then you know behaving themselves
when they're around people who are of a
different color it's not like that okay
there is a desire to have those people
show up and get the job because for one
thing it takes the pressure off to the
extent that departments don't look like
the demographics of the country in which
these departments are housed you know
that raises questions and so there's a
desire to bring in anybody who makes it
clear that that's not going on however
let's say that you were you were black
and you grew up in a neighborhood where
the odds were stacked against you and
you made it let's say that um you know
yeah you had people who said wise things
to you and they got you to focus on the
right stuff and you managed to dodge the
stuff that captures so many and you made
it right let's say you got into Harvard
you got a really good quality degree in
a in a in a proper science well what are
you gonna do with it you're gonna go
into academia that would be insane
because I don't know what the numbers
are I don't know what fraction of people
who get PhDs actually get the job
they've trained for but it's tiny
is it really I'll be like one in twenty
really yeah because there's only so many
positions and every year you're
graduating hundreds and hundreds of
people with those degrees well but
there's also a very good reason for this
I mean it's a terrible reason but
there's a very easily comprehended
reason so universities are fueled in
large measure by what's called overhead
of the grants so if you get a million
dollar grant half or more will go to
your university right so that's what
builds the buildings and fuels to place
so the university has an incentive to
get as many people file grant
applications as they can and they have
an incentive to hire people whose grant
applications will be large rather than
small so this for example is one of the
reasons that science has taken up arms
against theory that is to say proper
scientific theoreticians like me and it
is instead hired people who run big
expensive experiments because big
expensive experiments have big grants
and those big grants bring in money but
if you were a university and what you
wanted was to have people writing big
expensive grants who were capable
getting them then what you would want to
do is you would want to free those
people from teaching and you would want
to get people who weren't so expensive
to do the work of the university and the
way you do that is you bring them on as
graduate students and you pay them an
appalling wage you claim you claim that
they are not actually workers that they
are students and they they do most of
the teaching and they do a lot of the
work of the university for incredibly
low amounts of money they live under
poor conditions and increasingly they
have to come from abroad where they are
in some sense getting a deal that still
makes sense but this means that we over
produce PhDs we give people degrees
instead of money to do the work of the
university in order that the people who
are capable of getting the grants spend
almost full-time doing that job and it's
a racket hmm so in that what I wasn't
aware of that at all I didn't know how
it works yeah it's a racket and and the
person you should talk to the person who
knows the most about this is actually
Eric my brother mhm so what he unearthed
was actually that there was an explicit
conspiracy to game the visa system in
order to keep the system running that in
fact effectively a fake shortage of
science students was created to allow
the universities to basically flood the
market to drive the wages down but all
of these things mean that if you are
coming from circumstances that have been
challenging and you make it you don't
want to go to graduate school in the
sciences because it's a dumb move you're
going to take having gotten your head
above water and then you're gonna
voluntarily drown and it doesn't make
any sense you're much better off even as
bad as you know being a doctor has
become it used to be a great job now
it's kind of a sucky job but you're
better off doing that because at least
it's a job you'll pay off your loans
you know you'll make it and so basically
what we see is that there are lots of
reasons that a rational person from
certain demographics is less likely to
go into the sciences that's not racism
in the sciences it's again one of these
echoes of a past racism or a past
indifference that is having huge impact
on the present
hmm okay so these people that want to
that think that stem is racist and they
want to dismantle it what do they
propose like what would do they propose
a replacement of stem and academia so I
what they want is so strange and
preposterous that it damages my
credibility to even say it I will I will
answer your question okay
but I know that what I'm saying sounds
preposterous so the only reason that I'm
so certain of it is that I've talked to
them directly and I watched this happen
and every talk to them correct directly
so you know this is actually what they
want well I can't say they because
undoubtedly there's variation but I can
say that to the extent that I've
actually had these conversations with
people I was left completely shocked by
you know there was an it there was an
example at Evergreen where we were in a
faculty meeting and I said that the
proposals that were moving through were
a threat to the Enlightenment values
that were the basis of the institution
and what I got back was something I had
never heard before which was an attack
not only on the Enlightenment but on the
idea of enlightenment I was just so
stunned I was a college professor
amongst faculty and somebody was
actually saying out loud that
enlightenment was a problem and nobody
in the room said anything what did they
mean by enlightenment as a problem well
so here's here's what I say to two
people who asked me about this students
in particular the Enlightenment was a
European project right
it definitely had a light skin tone
right it was it was European men it was
not a Jewish project but I am NOT
embarrassed about taking the tools of
the Enlightenment and wielding they
don't belong to Europe right they're
human they're human tools they were a
discovery in Europe and arguably the
discovery in Europe
happened because of unfair exclusion of
other people but at some level who the
[ __ ] cares those are the most powerful
tools ever and you you can't uninvent
them the thing to do is distribute them
as broadly as possible mm-hmm but if
you're in critical theory first of all
if you end up in critical theory any one
of these fields women's studies queer
studies whatever it is you have already
foregone this option you don't end up in
critical theory if you have the chops to
do science so in effect you have people
who don't stand to personally benefit
from opening those doors wider because
they wouldn't go through them arguing
that nobody should go through those
doors so let's take a sidestep here
critical theory when you're talking
about gender studies or queer studies or
why do you think those are not valid
avenues for people to pursue well
because the method is non-existent
if you were to do these things properly
you would study them with the tools of
stem right but we know from we know
that's not what goes on inside of these
departments and we also know that the
product doesn't add up from the point of
view of science you can't take the claim
for example that if a man decides that
he is a woman than he is a woman it's
not a valid claim it just doesn't stand
up and you can't claim that sex is a
spectrum either that claim doesn't stand
up these are empty and we could have a
discussion about what we are to do in
light of the part of gender that is
flexible but we're not having that
conversation because we've got an
ultimatum on the table either you agree
sex is a spectrum or you're the enemy so
all I would say is just empirically this
is what happens now I will also say one
of the most telling incidents that
happened during the evergreen riots is
now finally it's been covered by PBS
I've talked about it on my podcast
a student of Heather and mine an
excellent student one of the best ones
we ever had as a young woman named a
debt a debt is half black
her mom's afro-caribbean she was known
to be my student and Heather student
during the riots and she was actually
confronted and physically bullied by the
rioters who accused her of being a race
traitor for studying science this
actually happened and what I'm telling
you
what did they say when they say you're a
race traitor for studying science what
what's what specific discipline well she
was studying evolutionary biology with
Heather and me and and they said you
were a race traitor for studying
evolutionary biology because because
science is racist it's nonsense
and I hear you trying to parse it as if
it makes sense and I think that we don't
understand as a person who spent three
years barely paying attention in college
I don't know how it got to that I don't
know how that becomes an actual course I
don't know how that gets funded I don't
know how that you can get a degree from
that well so what I've heard of late and
I'm it may be James Lindsay who is the
originator of of this phraseology but
there's a term racism of the gaps and
racism of the gaps is a reference to the
god of the gaps hypothesis anything we
can't explain in science is explained by
God which is obviously nonsense but
racism of the gap says any place where
that we see a success differential the
explanation is inherently racism so if
we see an absence of black people in
math obviously the answer is racist do
they apply that in areas where black
people excel no because this is a self
serving modality like hip-hop right and
so let's go back to a debt for a second
trying to parse what they're saying as
if it has content logical content is a
mistake mm-hmm trying to parse it as a
tactical
move makes a lot of sense okay let's
imagine that Odette was not the
courageous person that she is and that
she had caved right imagine you're
cornered you know you're alone you've
got a mob that's actually physically
confronting you for studying science if
she was not a person of strong character
she might have signed up with them if
she had signed up with them then eh now
they have a potentially powerful ally
right a black person former student of
or at that point I guess current student
of Heather in mine who would say yes in
fact science is racist evolutionary
biology particularly so I was in that
class yada yada yada and people are
easily influenced and that man being
bullied by that would probably cause a
lot of people to cave into that and give
in to that just for conformity just so
the people who accept them yes
and so thank goodness that Odette is
somebody who is of incredibly strong
character who really got the message of
evolutionary biology very deeply and
there's nothing that they could have
said or threatened her with it would
have caused her to make the move that
they wanted her to make but processing
it tactically is important what they're
doing is tactical and what they did with
shut down stem tactical they were
proving their power right they were able
to get the most important scientific
institutions to broadcast a demand to
shut down stem that's an amazing level
of power and actual scientists that are
in disciplines that are legit like
evolutionary biology went along with
them well you know I contacted Richard
Dawkins as this was happening hmm
because I didn't see anything on his
feed that suggested you know he hadn't
made a statement I thought it would be
powerful him to do for him to do it he
was totally unaware it was going on
right so you have the most important
institutions broadcasting this thing
something about our environment is not
calling it to the attention of people
who might be in a position to say
something and the whole thing is it's
setting us up we're in we're in
tremendous danger and what what do you
think their motivation is power power
well again what happens will that get
through they shut down
then what do they do how you know did
they are they thinking this far ahead
they're not playing this long game um
okay I would just I would tell people
who aren't aware of me and what I think
and believe that I am very progressive I
am very interested in making a fair
system as a my cousin line I know you I
know you are so what I'm about to say
sounds like one of those right-wing
crazy things Oh what they want well
imagine the following look first of all
let's talk about reparations for a
second okay okay I am NOT a fan of the
idea of reparations I think it would be
a terrible failure it would be a
disaster but I do believe that something
of very substantial magnitude is
justified I just don't think reparations
is the answer I completely agree okay I
think reform in terms of communities I
think spending massive amounts of money
to rebuild communities and give people
hope yes economic opportunities massive
investment yeah communities that have
been systemically frozen out and I will
put I would put American blacks and
American Indians at the top of the list
because I believe they have a special
claim is a protective Americans are
particularly distraught because they've
been subjugated to this weird position
when they're stuck on these reservations
so we'll come back to this maybe but I
think that there's something very
special that happened with blacks and
with Indians yeah not it's not exactly
alike but it has to do with their
different origin stories that these two
populations have both suffered a
parallel I don't even know what to call
it an obstacle yeah that doesn't that
makes them unlike anyone other America
yes yes so not in favor of reparations
but I would be in favor of something
that did the job that reparations are
imagined to do okay what this movement
is is an attempt to create a slant in
every single interaction that does the
job of reparations its reparations 24
hours a day seven days a week in every
room in every institution in
every context right now that will be the
uninvent of america it is in some weird
sense a mirror for the America that
blacks and Indians have faced they have
faced an America in which everything was
slanted against them it has grown less
so but again we have the echoes of that
deeply slanted America that are
broadcast into the present at a high
level of intensity but you cannot do
reparations inside of every institution
every hour every discussion that is not
a plausible plan even people who support
the idea of monetary reparations of the
solution if they understood the dynamics
of trying to infuse it into every
interaction there is no way it could
possibly work and it invalidates all of
the most important principles on which
America runs so we are really talking
about uninvent America and substituting
a reparations program for it which it
just couldn't possibly be a bigger
hazard and think think for a second if
you're trying to imagine what the hell
I'm talking about mm-hmm imagine the
courts right now there is a problem
there's a process called jury
nullification and Eric has pointed out
that jury nullification is a huge hazard
in an era where people are saying is
much a nonsense about who's guilty and
who's innocent and what it has to do
with race as we have because effectively
you can instantly create a situation in
which the law doesn't apply to certain
folks because of the color of their skin
right that would be an advantage you
could argue that it was compensatory for
years of being on the other end of that
deal but it cannot be made to function
but the other thing is also possible
right you can not only have the law not
apply to people on the basis that they
have a skin color that suggests they've
had a raw deal but you can also make the
law apply to people because of their
skin color we can have show trials right
I was effectively exposed to the
equivalent of a field trial at Evergreen
right I was convicted of racism and it
happened
that for various reasons I knew damn
well that the charge was completely
empty based on my history as a human
being and so I felt I could stand up to
it and withstand it and I guess in a way
I did on the other hand my wife and I
were driven out of the college so yes I
survived it but I didn't survive it
intact alright I made it somewhere else
but that show trial mentality I mean it
would be a perfect fit for the the
Maoist part of this of this movements
ethos I mean we're already seeing
struggle sessions people being forced to
admit things that aren't true right
[Applause]